[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
that was time really well actually with
the music I didn't expect that what up
everyone how's it going my name's Ben
and I've got it says erekt a but I'm not
quite sure who's with me right now a
real demon type funny the arcane skin
from apex legend oh yeah yeah it has
like this a similar mask we out okay
enough enough of that we're here to play
some Sakura
for you guys I thought about playing
through that but it'd be too hot
yeah I was gonna say it's probably get
real warm and toasty I'm just gonna
switch the game cuz I got a new game
here people don't hope I don't lose any
save stuff yeah right you're you are
currently risking your whatever your
game but we're starting from the very
beginning if you guys are worried about
spoilers if I won't get a single khumba
that's trying me trying to help you out
you know yeah got this intro seemed so
long ago
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
that's what I would do for that so poke
it's a classic maneuver look how it just
being fight four swords clanging and
grunting yeah there's not too many of
these
not a soul
got him yeah it's the same thing great
box Thanks
this just came for you
[Music]
no no in folklore assalamo Gustavo
Oh Monique Roberto oh poor poor boy
swoosh Tina
yabba de la Renta Okamura sooner oh no
see Dukes tatsunoshin of it or not you
know he knows
we are not in it
to grow
energy pushed through the blue looks
tired already
he's weathered he really is
[Music]
is that is that is that nice to it okay
like I don't I don't understand how you
would get sliced in the face even if
it's not that deep of a cut and not like
react at all
we gotta be like dead inside or
something yeah when you've got nothing
left to lose nothing fazes you you know
I'll show you
well they're V no English I just never
play don't even know if the game has an
English dub option I do it I can't talk
about scores at all review embargo I
think is tomorrow ish so stay tuned
we'll eventually get that up yeah yeah
to see but for now we are only allowed
to show up to so much we're gonna play
about 90 minutes ish so yeah try not to
spoil too much we'll try to answer
questions is that we're kind of allowed
to based off of where we can go to I
don't know how far we're we're gonna get
to try out different stuff
[Music]
I can't believe Jonathan Secor I've just
got his invitation to smash how dare you
tease people that way Yeah right
[Music]
he looks tired everywhere this kind of
reminds me more like Souls II stuff
though like how you always start off
kind of like slumped over yeah like
middle-aged man now we've had a bit of a
time skip but it's alright it's okay it
seems so long ago yeah right Kiros wolf
you'll find out what that is in a second
hopefully hopefully I don't screw up
I've been playing my character who's so
much higher level than this one that uh
you know Oh teach me how to jump you
gotta get used to not having skills you
had before and everything else yeah or
the lack of skills it's gonna be it's
gonna be an arson time but it should be
pretty good I think I hope that okay so
I totally thought there'd be something
back there but there isn't I think I'm
almost positive like whatever
what up Andrew and gray fox and
everyone's sorry I haven't been able to
say hi to everybody because we're
getting in the mood for for second rope
but do you know about sneaking a called
me I did until more recently crime wants
to know do we get a classic script to
death at the beginning you'll have to
wait and find out and they see me
that the guys not stoked about you being
here is in that Packard what can I say
I've never have you been able to stealth
pass that part without them seeing you
cuz I feel like it all really sorry I
stole this this whole you know I mean
yeah yeah I like where he didn't even
see you yeah oh really okay for me like
I felt like I was like oh cool I'm like
totally like what like doing this
properly you know and also I totally
didn't I didn't recognize this place
Oh until later yeah yeah yeah so that's
that's a thing whoever put the Japanese
voice over high five this is the way the
game actually starts off with the
Japanese absolutely never I can't do dub
yeah they actually put like a thing at
the beginning where they're like hey
scheme is in Japanese get ready for it
we'll get you past there at the gob war
yes with good ol it's been too long
Joey toaster
hmm
when will do argue alright sword time
gray fox says getting a good tent you
vibe from this game it's very tenchu i
don't play don't you so I knew of it by
never yeah it's it's pretty similar but
like I haven't gotten any poison rice
balls yet still waiting on that but its
[Music]
konichiwa next Arace on how one is
blocking us i one block a to jump i
guess you get a red plate for text
alright we got to talk to him to get our
first yeah really weird without things
business i'm just thinking about all the
abilities that you you have unlocked as
you're playing all the healing guards i
have yeah do you attack with square are
we able to show just the control take us
out of the castle bernard it's tomorrow
tea jam it might look that way but
you'll soon and point out that what you
thought you knew may not work the way
you think you want it to alright so i
got to go into here anyways here's the
kind of like menus I'm gonna put the
gourd the healing gourd okay yeah oh
wait forgot worthy things just in
options there we go so you've got your
prosthetic on right trigger RB is attack
grappling hook is on left trigger
deflecting and blocking his on left
bumper jumping it's got a dedicated jump
button dodging is on a dedicated button
general action is on X cycling through
your prosthetics is why and all your
items are on the d-pad you get that
combat arms at some point which will
level up eventually
yeah so that's the layout you're looking
at shitty he'll having a jump button in
one of these games is so this is like
your supplementary type he'll you only
get to my knowledge up to three pellets
at one time though you can eventually
store them yeah but uh hopefully I don't
need to use the colors so McMahon asks
is a character creation in this no so
you actually play as this character no
matter what you're doing which is kind
of cool because I think it gives them
more story yeah options so we are on PC
that's the answer to that this game is
heavily about posture this is a
Shinobi's not about just cutting down
their their foes thrower we do this
stealth kills is also pretty important
there you go you get that perfect parry
kind of thing if you perfect parry like
the lighter guys you can get that free
rvo it oh I don't have that do I have it
oh they don't do anything yet alright it
doesn't say I don't think oh this is
where they tell you about deflection so
glad I've played enough of this game to
be able to pull some of that off yeah
yeah all right lock on yeah so this is
basically the tutorial level we try to
get through it
[Music]
it feels really good beating up the the
week I say this tutorial does a very
good job I don't know that I could die
actually you've gotta let them get a hit
you know so that's that's a thing also I
want to like before we get like into
this into this this game is hard yep uh
I had the struggles for sure that you
will all realize that the struggles are
real like like I'm gonna just double
down not unlike the usual like ah it's a
Souls game it's hard hard like I
remember having to beat this guy
this game is hard oh I ain't beating him
I because I felt like I needed a fight
every guard so I just used the objects
use a pellet whatever so give myself the
best chance the way that I did this was
I got him to come out I ran away so that
he'd not follow me to get one then I got
the one free self I'm gonna just go for
it do the thing so this is the first
kind of taste of the games many many
bosses that it purpose it you where I
guess I can kind of sense a little
longer fight maybe explain what's going
on on the screen so at the top you'll
see that kind of red yellow bar that was
building up that's the enemy's posture
and by doing like well time deflects
attacks against them that they have to
block you build up that meter and if you
fill it up you get the killing them so
bad yeah bad at all stars its
intimidating so and nothing it's fine
that's not the the main thing about the
way the comment works is like you don't
actually attack their vitality and if
you do actually it hits on them it does
drain it a bit and it makes it more
difficult for them to regain posture so
you're kind of like attacking straight
up is kind of like a weird indirect way
to do fights it's super weird and in
interesting though
the point of getting on the tree is
their co-op in this a strong new no
co-op there's only like one time ever
that I was like oh it's kind of like an
NPC that can help yeah I think I might
be thinking of the same one yeah and you
don't even have to use them if you don't
want to yeah all right so far so good
chat yeah this is this is important
oh yeah he's dropping always eavesdrop
whenever you can because you'll find out
where items are hidden things you learn
about bosses or enemies up ahead it
almost always gives you some type of
hint or a tactic to kind of prep you
like kind of like oh like you should use
this against this or you know such and
such you'll see as we get farther along
here there is a sprint button you hold
be like kind of like the interesting
thing though because there's no co-op or
invasions you can actually pause the
game yep it's a really big game changer
yeah you don't think about it a lot but
being able to pause a game like this is
kind of nice yeah I mean it's not
necessarily gonna save you but it does
help you in those cases where maybe you
didn't have like an antidote or
something equipped and you're like I'm
poisoned and you need to like get
through your menus you won't get
actually hit you won't get hit like when
people are talking though I just like it
because I just go like I always try to
explore but yeah there isn't too much
around I'd say just go but no I
appreciate the pause feature because now
whenever my like pizza pockets are
almost done I can pause the game go get
them out of the oven
nice that's smart no rune food 2310
Sammy not too many Cinemax these are
kind of the one this is kind of what you
can expect to see like for story moments
and things like that that first cutscene
is kind of like the only rule on UC GUI
character design reminds me of something
from like the ultraviolent 90s animes or
the late 80s yeah it's a
cool design I'm very into it similar to
Dark Souls it's it's very dark souls in
its design because I think that's the
way it's meant to be set up but are
there monsters I mean are there are
there monsters too
I've just wait and find out don't know
you have to see well actually maybe be
able to get will be able to show some
stuff off other than just these like oh
right already in the end of Metal Gear
Solid 3 can't believe it did it so crime
about that you wouldn't call this a
cutscene right this is more like in
games yeah it's like a name thing it's
not a full-on cutscene
oh no
don't worry master yes there were some
things in some of the trailers like like
monster wise no fashion souls is merely
a deal breaker for me yeah King funder I
you know I thought about that too but
it's not that big of a deal something I
thought it would kind of bother me not
being able to change around my outfit or
like see like that kind of progressions
on my character but I'm kind of into it
looks like the game emboss place good
luck to us been pulling metal gear
rising to prepare for this the bad call
yeah
that kicks bro I'd even think about it
but like how cool would it have been if
like every single sword slash she did
like cut down the plants around you hey
I also just yeah not even bother I mean
it's up to you it's gonna he's gonna get
me regardless
don't even have mercury oh that's right
you don't even have that main counter
I can't believe give this man a hand
it's scripted by the way I'm curious
though if it's doable yeah I kind of I
think it definitely would be like with
enough just time on your hands but like
it wouldn't make sense canonically
though yeah right like what if you could
beat the game with like like a double
mint or DMC 5 situation yeah we're like
a far cry yeah yeah like that
oh yeah just chill whatever do you think
Sakura is more difficult than me oh I
think I always think back to like the
neo where ortho G neo like the Alpha neo
Alvin yo was yeah raisi before all the
adjustment durability and like just like
to shotty yeah getting to shot it and
all that stuff you know I played I've I
can I guess I can say I've beaten both
they're kind of different they're
different I don't know how to explain it
though I still think that this game
aligns more with tenchu and neo lines
more with like like a hybrid of like uh
it's like a ninja gaiden yeah is why I'm
really into it that's fair it's like got
like a harder more deliberate ninja
gaiden what my hand
do you member only first all the trailer
like what is going on dude it was also
correct me if I'm uh
correct me if I'm wrong I could have
sworn you there it was a kunai in the
middle maybe trailer but I'm sure stuff
may be changed dude 100% bombing
Tachibana like very similar to that
fight in you that that setting is like
almost identical even like fighting
Tachibana versus and
can you tear Oh like they are like very
simple subversion yeah what they have
equipped weapon wise like yeah anyways
yes you can backtrack for secrets if you
screw up um to an extent I guess so yes
you can also straight up miss things
yeah I've missed a lot yeah so much it's
very easy it's definitely one of those
like very Souls II games where my
experience can differ from been yeah
could differ from anyone else's in terms
of like how you approach it what you see
when you see it even me and John Luke's
experiences were very different like he
did something that I didn't do I did
something he didn't do yeah let's ask
about her farm I still like that somehow
I I stumbled into like a whole bunch of
stuff that no one had seen and I was way
behind everyone oh right yeah we can
maybe do that okay we could show it for
sure alright like I think it's within
reason yeah it's it's in that area so
it's it's not to jail so is there
grinding in this game yes to some degree
only because you basically have skills
you can level up shinobi tools we need
some tools I don't believe there's
English for science yeah hi Jonathan how
you doing
all right just can't move past it
there's a lot of a lot of exposition
dump happen it's like you should be
doing all this stuff like when is the
embargo I think technically review
embargo is tomorrow and I think the game
comes out Friday so I'm not sure if like
just because review embark we always
tread lightly and boilers and stuff like
that when it comes to that but
technically there is a New Game+ I can
tell I I don't know if that's just
boiler whatever I mean I feel like every
one of these games has had one I'm so
shocked the Dark Souls game because okay
like I said there are multiple
situations you can run into multiple
decisions and things like that that you
can you know make and whatnot so like
obviously you can't do that all in one
playthrough so you have to like and you
can miss things right so you always want
to be able to go back oh right so
there's the the training dude yeah I
like him he's really cool okay so douche
I show that for a second or you think we
should just progress basically there's a
trainer dude here he's like an attack
dummy he can't die
so you can just kind of like well I
didn't try stuff and the intro to him is
kind of kind of cool if you want alright
just kind of get like an idea who is so
he's always here at the beginning what's
your name I don't have any Okami you
have the look of a skilled shinobi
tsukumo he knows heed my humble request
face me in battle face me yet shouldn't
tested me man why'd you do that
look how he stands up in the most
unnatural way
could you imagine trying to get up like
that yeah right still alive yeah then he
just kind of introduces himself and he's
like yeah I can't die you're welcome to
practice your moves on me anytime you
want oh I didn't I didn't I haven't seen
anything pop up in there yet but okay
I've like never come to check actually
oh really oh yes we're playing on PC do
you want me to keep talking on that's
very good all right you have the general
gist all right let's get our first kind
of like these are the idols kind of like
your bonfire checkpoint stuff those
sculptors idols hearing there's a way to
I don't know yeah he's you know maybe
he's had a lot of time to sit there and
think about things he hasn't had a lot
of time to practice fights so grappling
hook is you know pretty key for
traversal and I like ally and it's the
the grappling hook for me is one of my
favorite parts just because it it's the
thing that makes it stand out the most
and it gives you a lot of verticality
and movement options and it also feels
really good to use yeah I wish
could maybe it'd be too much oh you're
just trying to like plan out where where
you're gonna take us no just so much I
was thinking about like how maybe they
could have incorporated grapple more as
they like actual like tack mechanic type
thing ah but it's more for movement
things like that you can use it you can
use it to attack in some ways but the
opportunities don't present themselves
very often so as mentioned you want to
like yeah that air assassination this is
a weird one for me why why why this
though why do I have to vacuum it into
myself I kind of appreciate you don't
have to run over them to give it I guess
but sometimes I'm just like I'm already
there like just give it to me instead I
have to always remember to like a vacuum
it up yeah okay ceramic shards did you
ever really use them I never I keep
trying to and I can't see any effect I
know they're supposed to be distractions
right but like I'll throw one next to
people and it they won't notice it you
saw nothing who throws a rock at you
like that's gonna do something also one
of my favorite touches I love how the
camera pulls in when you do one of those
finishing moves and it does a good job
of showing off like the facial
expressions on whoever you're stabbing
how he was in the grass damn the the
jumping on him one is kind of covering
what oh okay I was like the other guy
like that's my bed he's still good
yeah good I thought it was that guy cuz
like I saw the yellow indicator I was
like how do you see me that's the one
weird thing every now and then I have
those moments where it's like oh cool
how did he not see me and then there's
the other moments worth like how the
hell did he see me yeah self is an
interesting thing like watch like you
would think this guy would be able to
like you know uses peripheral okay well
he does that peripherals anymore but
they're like a grapple assassinate move
no I haven't run into one there is a
thing you can get where like on your way
up you can kind of like spin around with
your sword and attack someone that
you're grappling towards if I grapple
he'll see me probably huh no yeah he's
looking right there I'll talk about that
one but then yeah whatever we're just
going to try to stealth kill this car
deal with the rest of them there it is
and I need that one ability yeah yeah
yeah there he is sleeping soon a good
job hiding over there mind me
yes we're pro so hello or cray I don't
know I've been playing on PC so sorry
Zane I sacrificed okay oops sugars if
you're curious I like actually played
yeah I mean without it I tried using it
a little bit but I keep forgetting I
have them so it's basically a consumable
there's different kinds of candy
basically that you can consume that do
different things
oh these are these are these are fun
little boys what is very vivid yeah they
do a good job of making it stand out the
other thing too talking to some Matt
who's been playing the game as well and
he points out like a really interesting
thing where
I like that a lot sorry my my dudes your
strays you're like bad yeah yes they're
bad dogs ah he was pointing out an
interesting thing about the audio design
in that when you just attack and hit
someone with your sword like it doesn't
it's not hard or impactful like you'd
kind of expect it to be because most the
emphasis is shifted on to the the
blocking and the countering they're much
louder and much more intense when you
actually pull them off to kind of
incentivize you to do it check back with
the oh dude adders anyway yeah that's
you get a first prosthetic upgrade from
throw cool ninja stars
alright let's go do that real quick is
Sakura an open world free roaming game
it's open world and you can kind of free
roam and go back and forth and stuff but
it's not like you come into a large open
area go multiple ways kind of there's no
multiplayer so if you didn't guess there
like I have the power to come back to
life because shadows die twice that's
all they showed at the end of the first
teaser right it's just shadows eyes was
I think they didn't put Sekulow in there
nothing yeah yeah which is a tension
thing yeah it's one of the boss lines or
something
what's up Stefania hello I like Lea just
call it medicinal water like there's no
like explanation of what's in there yeah
it'll heal you if you drink it trust me
hi sorry I'm gonna so if you were stuff
she will help you upgrade it which we
don't have right now hopefully we find
something get you over a bigger glass to
drink your medicinal water out of
I'm gonna try to like show you guys more
gameplay so I'm gonna skip through some
of those for you guys yeah let's get
past that the next positional stuff and
get back into the jumping around so
every time you find one you come back to
the sculptor don't do anything funny
with don't even think about it
all right you got it all right so the
prosthetic tool you get up to three that
you can eventually cycle through we have
the sure can of which we don't have any
currency for it right now told that so
you get spirit emblems from time to time
you get them off like defeating enemies
to the surfaces yourself or for your
prosthetics you can buy them as well
mark asks about the voice acting so the
game actually starts off to faulted in
Japanese with subtitles
I don't how do we know if there is an
English voice option I never even
bothered to look I never looked either
but I don't think it there is doesn't
look like it like it yeah didn't look
like it
lots of in-game options no it might just
mean Japanese yeah so we're fine
obviously for the person asked oh no
this is fine
this is fine to the dogs here me
I always just I don't know why always
and I'm crouching invite-only to alright
another mini-boss and crouching does
make a difference to when you're trying
to sneak also hugging walls very good
like I didn't realize how house how good
it was it oh you're getting your [ __ ]
this is I think this is the first point
I died
yeah I think was when I was playing this
guy you gotta jump sleeping attacks home
at the game even tells you that no just
told you about perilous attacks in
general first and that's about it
bold moves I like it yeah
Oh bad bad bad it's fine it's just one
hit your posture is looking real rough
oh my god thank you
oh by the way you kids safely roll out
of things look it's got a pop these
tutorials up at some point I guess they
gave me a little bit of audio oh yes
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah
there it is
today okay yeah sorry I just need it for
the like sometimes I feel like I get the
audio cue a little bit from the
sword-swinging and stuff like that it's
important it helps me kind of figure
that out so should I just go back to
Emma probably huh like real quick
oh yeah just to get that just get the
second health guard Gord I think that's
a good good call might as well wear like
clothes yeah it's right around the
corner how's the performance on PC
really good aim it's I haven't run into
any issues myself playing on PC oh we
can try skull tree things stuff oh yeah
I haven't had any issues with PC I was
playing on a kind of beefier machine
though I've only had like one hard crash
but that was like something weird but
that was like one in like my 30
something plus hours or something oops
so luffa asks about the the read kanji
sign so what is what does that mean when
that pops up so it's a perilous attack
you cannot deflect that attack there's
different kinds eventually we'll get an
ability if I can show it to you here
that you can counter some of them by
doing a mercury counter but you have to
have that ability and it's mainly unlike
lunge attacks so the because you have a
jump you also have a jump counter and so
any sweeping attack you will want to I
guess we can I guess we don't have it
yet sorry any sweeping attack you have
to jump over yes you jump sweep attacks
you you kind of do the special counter
for thrusts and you can dodge or parry
other attacks our pit asking is it hard
in the Dark Souls it's harder in the
sense that what you thought you knew for
Dark Souls strategic-wise may not help
you as much as you think there's a lot
of us gained a lot of Dark Souls rules
that don't apply
here is going on the dogs going crazy oh
this is this area was tricky for me the
first time I went I went around and I
dealt with the guys under the tree first
that guy right yeah those guys right
yeah yeah I get that too but then it
triggers so gets the other guys to
follow you but then they all come up
over into that area and I just kind of
like fault it up and then broker find a
site with a nice drop here get there
should be the guy inside of the building
is actually good one to get before
everyone I got because he has a gun you
know just gonna go for it
I actually just did this area this
morning cuz I was like messing around
another fun tact is I just run around
like a crazy man oh yeah they don't know
walk here so you're never special attack
yet either yeah
the combat arts yeah yeah I actually
didn't use that that much I did I played
this game kind of wrong I think if there
is a way to play this game wrong I feel
like I did
can you save any time or their safe
spots it auto-saves and I think also
checkpoints anytime you're looking at
dummy
Wow okay sometimes like the tree
there's Auto staves and there are also
checkpoints when you use the idols or a
bonfire stand yeah and then you can
decide if you want to get help back or
sorry like get your human guards back or
if you want to just chill out so are
there any difficult parts are just
endless dialogue and killing you guys in
one to two hits it gets this is early
this is like that guy is annoying for
the first time when you see him they
Yammer dude so this is still kind of
like the whole using you into how the
game works and that the first very
difficult enemy we had to fight just a
little while back had a bunch of
tutorials pop up so this this isn't as
hard as it gets
I'm also like I have experience now so
like it's not really fair what I'm
showing I didn't use the balloons either
balloons either like you you're like
watching me and you're thinking like oh
this is this guy's making well I'd like
to think I'm making it look easy but
it's not it's it's an experience the
first time you play it
say that it's there's a lot of things
you're learning you do get
invulnerability we don't do finishers so
that's a big thing oh there's a kilogram
oh he's up top I think he's up here yeah
oh yeah like see dodging actually
sometimes isn't even though the best way
so the the problem that I have is I
always try to dodge backwards yep and
everyone does attacks that go forward
and they end up being further than my
dodge reach and that's the thing I need
to learn not to do I do it too so the
thing is like you can dodge attacks and
things like that but I feel like the
game really just wants you to deflect
and so you're probably better off
deflecting and you can multi deflect so
it's like in the in that case there if I
had done a better job I could
technically like you know yeah like
deflect deflect or if I deflect properly
on those guys I can just like insta-kill
get iframes and then deal with an other
guy but I'm not your son can't you can't
really totes going on bomb dad is fluid
huzzies huzzies re is correct there's no
stamina and he's they are saying you can
do anything what your well I would say
that you still have to be worried about
your posture yeah because if your
posture breaks you're probably gonna die
or get hurt real bad sorry if I'm
talking over some of the stuff here but
do enemies respond after you die yes
yeah
certain ones yeah if you if you be
larger like mini-bosses they don't come
back okay so this Bell is pretty
important we'll show you are in a little
bit we'll go back to a sculptor later
and we'll show you
yeah so she's like hey did you go like
show this thing to the Buddha yet did
you come down here I did yeah fight
fight these boys they're actually 5c
that's so dumb yeah I hate that like
you've knocked it out of the air but
then it's talyn's happens to hit use of
any again anyways so yeah like okay coin
purses you so when you die you lose
experience and you lose the money that
you've earned but you don't lose like
coin purses obviously yeah and there's
no way to get those back alright so here
we're gonna talk to this gentleman like
when you you die and you lose stuff it's
gone you can't run back to your previous
spot and grab it
my dude wait he sound familiar could it
be yeah we went to checkout yeah your
mom's literally right there
you could probably yell to her actually
she might be alright
Battle Royale but she died twice oh okay
I'm gonna show you guys a way around
this
this mother F there's like this guy only
shows up once well is it the the big why
are you doing this wrong because I
definitely don't want to go there you
can go you go up on top of that into the
left yeah this is the spot yeah yeah so
alright pro tip for those guys that that
guy like I just sucks yeah he's been
this is the the strategy to not having a
deal with that guy just go around you go
around there's always like a side path I
feel like so just look around look above
you because that guy has a cannon and he
basically artilleries you from downtown
and it effing sucks
she's very accurate yes yes he is
definitely very accurate this is these
are all facts
you lied live guides right now alright
live walkthrough
he's doing one of those he surprisingly
how are the health refills in this game
they get good as you I died
oh but are you gonna do it no no you
sure I don't have it oh yeah that's
right oh that was so stupid
sorry y'all hear this this is a good I
guess it's good that I don't have time
to show the story yeah oh man that feels
bad well now you can do it should I do
it yeah you know what he's walking away
get him I really don't want I really
didn't want to in the beginning but
whatever so you have the ability
resurrect now there are consequences as
many of you probably know to
resurrecting don't to say what it does I
don't probably shoot interesting I don't
know what there are consequences to
dying yeah and you probably don't want
to die big surprise you don't you don't
want to die in this game there are more
setbacks than just the fact of dying
yes we're playing on PC you get these
kind of hints do I feel like there's
like speed runnin or speed runs for this
game are gonna be very interesting to
watch because I feel like there is a lot
of stuff you can just skip and run past
yeah I could have skipped those guys but
doing it for the the experience belong
to site and okay quick mats and guides
to avoiding artillery fire I love it
this guy what are your first merchants
that night
are you gonna pay our gonna pay the man
yeah man Oh 50 is pretty steep okay so
another thing is in some cases like
these you can broker for information
that information helps you do other
stuff can you do a no-kill run like
Dishonored
I don't think so have be really tough
I'm sure someone's gonna try I mean
there are certain bosses you have to
have to kill though right
oh you're talking about oh sorry I was I
thought like no like revive sorry that's
what I mean yeah you can do that you
just not choose to revive try buy more
I only bought the one from when I'm like
this is okay he leads you to more stuff
oh no be tools it's in Hirata we'll go
get that in a bit yeah actually I healed
but technically there's a checkpoint
I knew that rooster yeah right up over
there
maybe we go now we just need a rest
what up goob how you how you doing uh
good wants know did they take any
elements from neo mmm I wouldn't say
that necessarily I mean there's like
abilities they didn't have abilities
technically in Souls II games are you
yeah like blood-borne never had skills
it was always tied to a weapon now
there's actual skills skills to learn
moves to do see like you think they call
that like I freaked out the first time I
like did that on accident thinking like
how perceptive you know are these guys
more he's dropping it's a something over
there in the distance sure I can hear
him
okay chime I mean I think I should yeah
I think you should try them only choice
is a you spire see so when you see red
eyes they fear fire so that's that's
handy information for when you get fire
things we got that brokered information
about a fire fire to like that fire tube
that we could potentially okay it worked
out perfect because they don't hear
footsteps I mean you are a shinobi
but there are tools later that make your
steps more quiet no equipment durability
alright here's this dude so I also only
was able to beat this guy once I got the
free hit off on him
see how we do here's your monster kind
of yes okay grab attacks see so you can
pull on when you can pull on him I
didn't even see you got the people's
elbow that thing is devastating if you
don't time it right I love how he just
kind of throws himself around see you're
sticking much closer to him than I did -
oh come on I'm scared dude I'm having a
battle here I was building up so much
posture you know I don't even have an
accurate counter for that guy oh yeah no
after you
that's what you sit up here in my tree
in sekito have a dang it this sucks
oh my god he'll sucks I just wanted to I
I can I can own this [ __ ] I was showing
you my tactics
I could totally own the crap out of this
over you know what's funny though he's
not um
losing the posture which is good because
you you got so much health oh this is
good maybe yeah yeah yeah
Oh God i frames Oh back to you whoa oh
no he's gonna toss you up on top of that
the hill oh no he's not gonna toss you
this did I yeah big step Oh
second one oh [ __ ] yeah normally cuz you
know I should show the the grapple
mechanic huh try to give it up we still
gotta get the second wife down anyways
see that's when I started realizing you
know what if they get a second one I get
a second one exactly oh my goodness
[Music]
Oh angle of the hill dang it man I all
right okay I'm gonna go fight that guy
again
yeah you can get a cellphone on him too
or a stealth yeah yeah uh okay so this
shows you what you lose I lost money
like I lost half my money and all my
experience or half mine sorry go ahead
yeah I ran away and I came back at him
again I did that so much no I will kill
him now yeah hey man this like I said
before this game is real hard I'm gonna
take any other hand I can get it I'm not
judging you
I just question is is there a way for me
to get to now you know what we just
might have to lure him away from the
spear dude I don't know how is the
effect
oh here grab on it set some off-kilter
and later on you get an attack you can
do off of that really yeah it's it
wasn't that one specific boss fight that
I realize ah totally planned a hundred
percent calculated they call me
spider-man
oh man there's there's a lot there's a
lot happening right now I need to I need
to take a second to breathe yeah
what excuse me it's okay
we're showing you all of the ogres
movesets Zorro's excuse for for us to
rate the game one out of ten we're not
gonna do that but you can wait for a
review when it happens it's in the works
it's on the way for you hey Red Hulk
how's it going oh yeah where's the life
barceló enemies of vitality is on the oh
I'm blocking it with the pit you are
walking with oh I got it
this is fine we're gonna we're gonna do
some hot swap here oh wow he get three
kicks
I'm just I'm not even gonna bring up the
preview to do it I'm just gonna people
are gonna watch me do it right in front
of them or you just lose the box and
then just move the camera it's already
there or we're already already moving it
stop there we go perfect stop doing big
yes give me people's elbow
I realized halfway through explaining
where the enemies help know that dad
okay you can't see it yeah
[Applause]
so the vitality is in the upper left and
my experience is not in the upper right
but whatever this fine suck it I didn't
see so you get you get the medicine rank
yeah buy some of it like I feel like I
don't know it the only way to learn such
techniques is to be gravely injured time
and time again my worthy opponents and
then like you level it up somehow
anyways alright we did a chat we didn't
we didn't need that fire cannon yeah I
didn't need that suppose it fire cannon
all rightie ways here we go ooh I never
use this thing either oh yeah hi I can
see far away now this a gourd seed a
little celebratory dance wiggle wiggle
alright this guy is okay we could show
off that the thing that I found we I
mean it's it's kind of a cool little
tease like a nice cool hidden things it
though I mean you don't have to actually
engage with it we just move past it
we show the yeah you want to go do the
thing right you show the thing past him
no I mean like it's so like I don't I
don't know what the rules are so I'm
kind of leaving I know all right
the rules are we're only allowed to show
up to like a certain area based off of a
like boss right yeah and so I mean in
you could argue that it's within the
scope but at the same time I just I
don't know I just don't know it'd be an
interesting thing on the stream to try
it and see how it works out
is it like here or is it after this it's
it's right next to you like to the right
I love the spirit dudes back though
actually not I think about it explain
the icon bars on the screen so bottom
left is your health and your chance to
come back oh it's a it's up yeah right
it's right next to the the samurai guy
the the next mini boss oh yes I got to
go there yeah yeah yeah that's what I
was asking
Oh gotcha like I'm not there yet you do
to get to that area yeah okay all right
so Oh
bottom left is your health and your
reviving attempts top left is the enemy
vitality the bottom yellow bar is your
poise bar and the top yellow bar is the
enemy poise bar and the poison bar is
basically like if you manage to get off
well-timed
parries it will increase the the bar and
it will make them easier to stagger
which will let you get a killing blow on
them the same thing happens to you the
controls are tight yes there's that guy
over there that's annoying AF will
happen if you don't follow the stream
rules actual Shinobi's will come and
find us yeah well we will get
assassinated they're literally standing
outside the door they're just watching
and waiting
yes there is no stamina but the the
poise bar is kind of a stand-in for
stamina only you got the person with the
bell up on top yeah trying to get to
them I just forgot this layout these
these efforts are like you could run
ahead to the point down by the okay
alright oh shoot we don't alright we
need that free one on the the Lord the
spear dude one of the thing that we
found let's down there huh it is right
down there yeah stop attacking me here
let me hide in the bushes
it's like GTA my wand will go down oh my
gosh yeah so staggering can be affected
by well time parries or even hits that
you do so it's kind of like a good mix
of just keeping pressure on the opponent
in any way you can every time that's a
lot of boys and we're we're handling the
situation flawlessly everything is fine
synch up heads coming to the switch yeah
maybe I'll finally be able to beat that
game because I'm also not that great at
that one go pay off that bounty at the
post office come I mean just get
subscribe our dear Lulu I'm very excited
for the crypt of the necrodancer
was a cadence oh boy I'm not ready for
you yet just vacuum in my money yep
thank you let me deal with your friends
first
are there difficulty settings not off
the bat there are moments though
sometimes if they're like mid-swing they
could possibly get you as you're coming
out of the friends yeah
cuphead DLC news yeah I'm excited that
more people will get to experience that
game though oh that's very awkward I'm
worried about the enemy AI and how long
it takes to go back into stealth see
there's that example of dodging I didn't
have dodged how do you guys feel about
this from what we've played it how much
can I talk about it I say it makes sense
from what I've experienced like if I
hide and hug a wall where they can't see
me they'll lose interests eventually
they learn to like not turn around and
walk back to their patrolling areas
they'll actually walk backwards so I
can't get an assassination on them but
uh okay ban I guess I'm just gonna fight
him I guess so
dang I would have I would have just ran
to a point or something and not dealt
with them this guy is real scary
that's a sweeping okay oh that's a
thrust what controller we're using for a
PC I think you're using a 360 controller
[Music]
is it difficult to be on par with any of
the other souls games I see it's on part
in some ways it might surpass it because
a lot of people who are coming from
Souls games into this might have an
interesting time adjusting to the
differences so I think you're supposed
to do the special counter which I don't
have it yeah exactly so thank you I
think you need to have it but for now
maybe sidestep because it's a forward
thrust boy you know why you know why and
I saw my posture and I freaked out okay
maybe this isn't happening right now
let's go touch on that other the other
point I fear I fibbed to you guys I'm
just gonna go for that
but that right and then once the will
right I don't know if you wanted to
check on the check point really quick
and like I mean go back but then all the
guns the one that's right next to you
forward oh you mean down below yeah okay
that's bad can shadows die more than
twice you'll have to play the game to
find out it's it's right there right
there right there I'm also gonna go to
mo real quick looks like we're about to
break controller to yeah it's a lot of
people were worried about it not being
challenging because you can revive
yourself it's it's still challenging I
heard you can dash into enemies to stop
param troll you can there is if some of
you I can't tell if he's serious or if
if someone were mashing the button to do
the special counter for certain perilous
attacks it could come out as a dash and
then into that counter because you're
mashing the button but I don't think
it's a dashing forward to actually use
to work she's explaining his blood helps
me revive just want it yes please
just give me my third one you cannot
couch co-op with a friend but you can
sit there and have a good time passing
the controller back and forth if you
really want to jam into it probably a
telemarketer so I could do the Buddha
thing I want to show that to you
maybe we'll go over 90 minutes yeah
you'll see we have up to two hours is
what I was informed upon so wait are we
going to show that now if you know what
I am down to do it I don't know you
remember what triggers him to give me
the scroll I think just talked to him
because he's like oh you're gonna really
do with this yeah because I'm really
close to the mercury counter which we do
need for the rust attacks the only
problem is sometimes it's hard to tell
do I just plays well with the mouse and
keyboard I haven't tried it because I'm
too afraid I can't even I'm not that
great with a controller and I'm okay
worried how now we have the esoteric
text which allows us to level up
abilities the counter that I'm talking
about the mccurry counter is - I believe
requires - so here's the skill tree
I need this ability yeah - and here's a
combat art but I need this for thrusting
attacks Jim took the Commodore because
that combat arts really nice and I think
it will it'll help you on your way to
get the counter
yeah but I'm so close look at how close
I know you're very close to it are you
know what for the chat we'll just get
that we'll just get the world and / I
got to remember to use it though I like
the world 1 / a lot I don't need to okay
so we're going to do that thing right
and you'll see the thing okay okay so it
would be better if you had fire against
not this guy though
combat arts yeah okay just probably run
past these guys are fine I mean you can
fight him that's cool too it is easier
the second time around cuz it's gonna be
so many more stealth murders and just
deal with the boss by himself yeah yeah
no little movie yeah they don't have
movies they've just got like drawn drawn
things to kind of show you what it does
almost like it's kind of late so it says
the swords and pikes did nothing let's
run back if you value your lifeless oh
dude am I gonna fail the jump you know
you're gonna be fine
isn't there like a crazy one though like
yeah this one this is the weird like
leap of faith cuz you might not notice
that yeah there you go it's all downhill
from here
pretty much I wonder if I mmm
so that I I found this by accident and
apparently it like heads off to like a
place that shows up later in the game or
something
it's it's a wild time yeah it's an
interesting thing is there a carry gun I
think so no you're good there's a
shortcut though you know that right for
you get back here you can you can open
it oh shoot is it over there
nothing so because I just like came here
this morning I just remember there's too
many thoughts going through my head
about this game so imagine me a person
who's like already scared because I'm
dying a whole bunch of this damn I came
into this cave just go to the cave just
go to the cave okay
yeah really are the short we can we can
get the shortcut on the way back
and you look over this edge of this cave
and you see that down there it's a real
gross boy with a giant glowy sword in
the dark I can't - I cannot sprint yeah
please don't do that one thing doctor
here nailed it oh yeah there is a
headless naked man I feel like I should
show the chat I mean it we can get it on
the way back so this this is another
cool touch you hug a wall go through a
secret a secret way damn I really want
to show it I really don't know if we
should though what do you think look at
this guy
hey man it's this is still 2 hours like
it's there right
technically look a door we can't open
okay so that's the door that you guys
came through no I did it this way you
did this way - ok
I don't think there is a Cary limit I
think I can just do you think this is ok
you know what I you know go for it yeah
do not ring this Bell inviting this
fortune is an act of virtue but only the
status of hearts should ever consider it
hmm of course after you read that you're
gonna do the first thing it tells you
not to do right no no no you do it no no
no you're not gonna do it no should I do
it I say you should do it really yeah
I don't even know what it looks like
dude yeah oh it's if you're worried
about it messing up that no you're fine
with that I have to do it again after no
you just do it from your inventory
[Music]
so
now there you go it's hard you're
possessed now possessed yeah your
possession would say this might make it
it might make the game more difficult
order it might be a harder mode okay but
if you do not want to engage with the
game and on a harder thing just going to
inventory and use it and it scares the
demon away it should be an inventory you
just kind of scroll down there it is
deep belt bill demon no go away don't
want you burden dispelled
everything's fine again so yeah you can
use a capetti against the the headless
dude I'm pretty confident I only just
recently killed him so I yeah yeah
that's that's a little bit of a tip for
if you want to activate that on your own
I have 167 and we just leveled up so we
shouldn't lose too much all right here
you know what I hope he doesn't grab to
us that I can let I know what the queue
is so real unless he kills me before
that
look at him woman did you see his other
hand yeah he's gross John we didn't know
about that really job the music isn't
isn't good
okay here I'm gonna let him do it so
normally you're supposed to like oh is
he coming
my butthole watchin watching put it into
his though I'm dying
yeah I would come back and tonight so
that is a doable side boss it took me a
while to figure it out but it's yeah
anyways it's not those things I lost 83
coin for you guys okay the wonderful
wild side adventure for everything all
right so we go back to here oh you know
what ha ha I kind of want to show her
odd it to you
alright I'm gonna give this boss guy hmm
ago despite not having mercury counter
oh woops wrong on spot where is this the
right spot no it's not the right spot
right didn't go Hearn
yeah well going this way Oh sir so we
have this guy go oops sorry this guy go
and then if I fail then I will go to the
estate just to show off the estate for a
little bit and Oh idiot item down there
whatever it can't be that important it's
probably more ceramic shards shards that
you can throw around did I miss
something the the God of War you only
you only missed a gross that girl was
this man full art took it from I want
the lore on that character took it from
why does he need to do that he collects
them you know fast travel not from a
start fast travel is unlocked as soon as
you find a connecting sculpture should I
can I do you think I can just sneak up
to him and do you'll probably get him
then back up and get the other guy yes
I'm thinking oh you think I can get this
guy first you get that guy on the side
and then back up and the worst case the
boss might follow you oh he's walking
away you're fine
yeah you're fine he doesn't turn around
then look he turns around that wasn't a
factor that was a factor I should have
just went for the boss first you get
this guy though
no almost everyone's clear just got the
guy on the corner just wanted to get the
free one on the boss because all the
like the minions and stuff are super
easy we do look at the everyone on the
boss just got a run a run far enough
run back yeah it should be up around
next to those wooden things see up high
like to reset this fight you might be
able to run down to where that point was
- oh is it RVs is it the trigger the
triggers to do to combat are it should
be left bumper so dirty both bumpers
yeah so left bumper right bumper it's
like as you're you're holding up to
block you hit attack oh that hit on buck
this in back you can hit them both at
the same time but that's kind of Hawaii
I went for it up you're right you're
probably right just uproot all of these
wooden blocks with my body can use other
weapons and armours there are other
prosthetics you can get but I don't
think he'd get like other katanas he's
already stopped following them because
as soon as his health bar disappears
you're good and what that free one but
I'm fighting kind of Gibbs yeah they had
to use two heals but whatever it's fine
I think it's fine III beat him without
using the counter cuz I just didn't know
how to use it wait what he might be
further back excuse me
he might have left this plane of
existence no he's he's here he's just
various very sweet boy running and
gunning
how long are you gonna patrol that way
[Music]
and then he's gonna like path back this
way isn't he
Wow okay can't remember this being this
way I there that's real stealthy what
the way you might have been able to jump
off the top of this thing to get to him
good how's the story told is it clear or
a vague it's kind of like there's still
a lot of like Dark Souls mystery at
least I'm just speaking from my
experience things to kind of figure out
but there's also a lot of stuff that's
kind of playing on the nose
nope they're on the real dough SEC euro
/ and run that's how I play it like I'll
I don't have any problem like running
away from a thing and coming back and
resetting the fight
[Music]
do you want to okay we're gonna try this
again I'm gonna try this again there's
no fence construction codes and in Japan
yeah man
just let anyone run into those things
and we're making the game looks so easy
now it's like hard hard because this is
when it starts being like oh by the way
you've actually got a plane out like
this is this is for real dad
I'll say it again this game is hard like
it's it's actually very difficult also I
made you pick a thing that you you don't
use very often instead of what you
actually needed can I just go for him no
you could try to jump off of like
something and get the aerial on him like
off of that that wall maybe I think so
just a little bit of extra clearance cuz
it does have a little bit of homing in
and it does it just make sure you're
locked onto him though
Oh No that's the Pat that's the hat see
ya anyway
sorry what
since when she's uh he's very dedicated
now since when so they're playing on PC
how this game distributed via Steam
shouldn't be live yet like crime says of
because we cover games we get early
access to make sure we can get our
review and other coverage ready for it
so we have like a press code press code
for it so we can actually make all of
that content so you think I could make
it from here maybe it seems really far
it wittily turns cuz then worst case you
can just kind of like follow through and
get them always padding oh my goodness
okay what yep that's how this game works
effects though that worked like a really
good distraction I guess
so if if anyone's wondering why it was
important to get that assassination
alfano it takes away a full part of his
life and basically makes half the fight
not a thing which is really good
for real though Jonathan I feel like
some of the enemies might like remember
you from when you die and they're like
oh I know he's gonna run over here I'm
saying I'm following you don't know what
to do
[Applause]
we do have the grapple it's you can only
use it on enemies at certain points in
time and you can only use it on certain
parts of the environment it's not like a
free use hook oh yeah ok we did it
you don't even need the governor you're
you're fine that was perfect
ok hirato I guess yeah sure
cuz this next part do they know what's
here
sure we could kill mentioned it cuz it's
in trailers really quick yeah it's a
real cool set piece I know it is
look just touch on the thing you can
revive if you need to but look at my
looking light Oh at least let's at least
get a skill then midair deflection I
mean midair deflection or do you want to
hold out for the actual count I know but
if I die to the thing that we're gonna
show I'm gonna lose yeah that's right
that's what I'm saying
yeah oh you're not gonna lose the one ok
ok you know what
here here do you think I'll get enough
by farming these boys here I think you
know what you'll probably get it if you
go back to the the thing with the bell
would probably be the place to get it
all out there's a whole bunch of stuff
you're gonna have to fight there too
let's see how that how much this
actually adds to the bar this show oh
yeah yeah we'll get there
assassinate is not a learned skill you
have it inherently so that's good
there's different cool stuff you can do
actually you might get enough yeah I
think I will she'll be able to people
over there yeah there's two over there
and the guy below I think yeah we're
gonna get there perfect
cuz you kind of need it for that one guy
too right you do it's a very important
skill come on do your thing there it is
alright let's go
level up real quick then oh my gold my
sweet gold my sweet sin yeah yeah yeah
well we'll sacrifice it for the chat as
per usual everything for the chat you
know what excuse me
yeah whatever I don't know what's left
of there right all right let's get them
McKee T count they're gonna get spear
dudes how big is the map it's pretty big
it's pretty big
it gets pretty big alright this is for
chat what's what's the rumbling what
could it possibly be Ben
I mean I know but I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna spoil the surprise what kind of
progression is in the game so you get
experience points towards skill points
that you then spend in the skill trees
there are a few a few different ones
that you can kind of work your way up
but that's the main thing that you used
to that's interesting should never
happen you would think that but no this
is also where I got the tutorial so I
was like I already done this a bunch
what is going on why is it
oh no what's happening
look at what are you doing a good job uh
teasing that he's gonna tease go my god
I just ran through the left side so I
didn't get this lucky you tomorrow that
you boy so this seems like it's the much
better way to do this or oh is that you
oh god you're you're dumb snake that's
game okay uh you can't lose I don't
think you can outright lose skill points
by dying no I just said sure they're
important no I think like if you're like
at level 1 you don't drop back from one
you like should I hope go look the other
way yeah yeah that's a good that's a
good that's a good heavy it's ok it's
fine it's fine it's fine
yeah I'm sorry
you want some reduce anyway just that
big snake from resin evil one the the
yawn is it cold
I think
was something else
I think Assad he had me I heard it it
was read it was no bueno I don't like
this he could oh my god no he can't he's
blind the blind snake he's a bad bad
snake has no tongue but it's got like
weird beard particles or something going
on you can't see its do this icicle you
know oh it's true everyone knows that
it's difficult to see things through ice
snake snake he does it okay yeah so I
need him to do that again did you know
he can go in that thing really I revived
oh I saw that thing and I was like
perfect
oh [ __ ] this is a different experience
is it I didn't get oh yeah and then you
and then you do this I didn't know you
could do that what
I literally revived and ran oh yeah
you're supposed to do it in your life
Oh oh my god okay lucky well keep
running don't stop oh I wanted to show
him I wanted to show chant that he gets
real angry you might you know my sneak
it doesn't have that really see yours
doesn't have doesn't have a messed up I
know oh shoot
wow that the more you know yeah see
we're still learning things even even
now wowzers I did not see that coming
hey he's done right I'm good I think I
hope I mean he's he's gotta go run away
his eyes all that stuff I don't know he
came to bite me after for a second you
know like alright uh hirato I guess I'm
gonna go grab this other thing real
quick just I can't help myself
yeah dude I am so bloody I call sugar
alright Hirata we gotta go - hurrah -
holy [ __ ] right yeah right okay I'm kind
of glad we did that actually I am too
glad we did that
you nearly died that was a clutch here I
did it was not clutch right I should
have been running but I wanted to show
how intense it get so like you got it
you got to show it right I dated now
it's even blinder yeah what if they got
that snake an eye patch you just be big
boss be very into that
[Music]
my disease spreads so basically she's
telling you if you revive or die stuff
starts happening
yeah sure this is a this is a firm soft
joint it uh it's an it's a new it's like
a weird take off of Souls Souls games
can you sheath your sword manually I
haven't found a way to do it personally
I don't know if you can all right so
we're gonna do this now
yeah heck yeah right yeah I said Hirata
you did for hirato right I started think
about Tekken for a bit I wish I haven't
done a sunglasses thing in a while over
a PT yeah this is PC
we get taken away thanks for baiting
yourself for us I'm surprised I actually
made it through that without really
getting hit I got super lucky that one
time yeah yeah that was uh it was
intense yeah alright so we're gonna go
get some old memories here are there
different sheaths in the game for some
like stylistic choices I don't think so
we're here
alright so far I enjoy it it definitely
frustrated me more the first time I
played it just being honest just because
I like I said earlier and a lot of
people even in the office I've said you
kind of have to unlearn some of the
muscle memory you have for Dark Souls
and kind of treat it like it's its own
thing because mechanically there's
definitely some stuff that is different
for obvious reasons
yeah jump now you have a grappling hook
deflect and postures like way more
important it's not necessarily always
about just straight up dodging anymore
like it used to be like you'd either
dodge or block with your oh gosh that's
not so great he's gonna see ya he's
gonna come over to you
so this whole part I thought that if I
got in the water
I would drown and I didn't mess with it
at all
heard that you kid yeah turns out you
can swim yeah you can swim which is
pretty cool that's also pretty different
yeah
how much harder is it I I think for me
it's it might be one of the harder souls
games I've played I don't know if it is
because of that that like carpe diem
having to learn stuff over again or or
whatever it is you swim so fast if you
do this yeah
no truck weapons are various so there's
those variants in the different
attachments you can get for the shinobi
arm or the the prosthetic arm and there
are different attacks and build you can
do from the skill trees so that's that's
kind of where the differences will come
out yeah but the thing is I barely use
my prosthetic
there are definitely use cases and the
game is pretty smart about telling you
some of these cases so I don't know how
to hit the ones that are down lower like
that okay cool
I like that guy top to your NPC bring
them to me oh you know I never bought
this from them I should although it's
not necessary but yeah this fragment
there's this oh you know what I need to
buy this from him yeah yeah these have
hints the text stuff it's also a comment
are oh is it yeah okay I've never buy it
it's not not so much like visual
differences outside of what you have
prosthetic wise but definitely in what
build your character goes there will
probably be some differences
has it got exploration like Dark Souls
yeah there is there still a lot to
explore and kind of poke around yeah so
like this area is like semi optional in
some way
very different one
tonight doesn't have it
cyborg man pointing out that we've
convinced them to to buy a lot of games
and not buy a lot of games and he values
the service that we we do wants to do it
hello
[ __ ] you haven't done that comment are
yeah we don't need to do it on these
walls that's fine they deserve to be
countered yeah I told you like I always
forget and I will try to do it it's it's
real good on some of these guys cuz
it'll actually knock their their poise
or whatever it is all the way off Dexter
all the way down so you're saying I
should hold block and then let it rip
right uh yeah or you can do it when
you're running up to someone
trying to feel like I'm doing the wrong
thing it's this and the other one oh you
know what it is man right bumper oh you
didn't equip it that would do it yeah I
was like dude I'm totally doing it
back yeah that one so why are we killing
these people because they're attacking
our our hometown and trying to take the
Prince right yeah they're trying to
kidnap the Prince that you're supposed
to protect so right now we're in a it's
a flashback to what happened kind of
before the the game started yeah I think
so how accurate is the timing for the
parry it's it's very accurate you don't
forgive you didn't mention though you
can kind of do this like you can tap a
me but as I told then as you get farther
later it becomes something you can kind
of do but if you mess up oh oh hi you
mess up your posture it kind of makes it
really like if you screw up rather it it
and you just block you take more posture
damage and then you get potentially
staggered easier so you just got to be
mindful of like spamming it neo is
harder because it's unfair boss present
yeah I feel like I feel like for me this
this game is more difficult than neo
though and I think it's just because
they they force you to kind of do more
defensive stuff and I'm I'm kind of like
not good at timing I think so
why would you do that to him he's one of
many people in my way
they're dogs here oh yeah there they
aren't you have to hold on just tap so
holding will be just a regular block and
tapping is when you do the parries this
is story good so far I've been kind of
into it like it's been enough to kind of
make me be like oh yeah I know where I'm
going I know what's going on my good for
a long range people and like a light
armor because you can kind of like knock
them down right in the fire oh they're
they're gonna talk about one of the guys
up ahead and I think they mentioned the
thing in the fire which definitely want
to pick that thing you like I didn't hit
wall there like that
what do you know like when you hear that
clink noise also going to arcs or bigger
when he went his all right so this is
all this but this thing was like you
could actually not it's hard to see so
there's a flame barrel that was the
prosthetic that thing was talking about
I found it by accident I kind of did too
I mean I I tried to do my due diligence
of like picking everything up and so it
does show it but I mean you could easily
have missed this yeah like I missed the
the axe for like the longest time and
it's it here too right or not it's
really good not physically where I'm at
but in in this area in Hirata what
button is lock-on clicking the right
stick r3
just gonna say we're got like what 20
minutes 20 minutes left try to hello-ski
she's telling you about the axe please
find the axe it's over to the left right
yeah it should be like up up that wall I
think this way see that you got you
gotta always be up above everyone
that's Dark Souls tactics here and I'm
open the door that shortcut back back
home you know you could just jump over
it won't expect you to be so close
together yeah it's it's interesting -
what - have two prosthetics that close
to each other should be in that to the
right legend grab yeah he turn around
for you
whose guy who should be in there yeah
unless he ran out are we thinking about
the wrong house I think we're both
thinking of that one out because I'm
pretty sure there was someone in there
it's in there yeah yeah that's how you
can miss this one too is if you cuz it's
inside of a thing you might not know you
can hope this would have saved me oh
yeah because you were you were fighting
the the enemies that were specifically
designed for it what about it
so people asking like how open this is
like you could do this area earlier or a
lot later and that's kind of what
happened to me I did the castle area
first don't you do it guys Callum just
what you're gonna like give me the free
one feels like he can cheese the back
step yes and no listen no sounds just
full of giant chickens
there you go see that's that's the
ticket
yeah butterflies a thing oh do they know
about that it was she's been shown off
in like half of the trailers we won't
get there for challenge yeah a little
bit too far easier than souls games I
still think it's harder for me it was
harder open up open up her ass but could
hear you whispering so that is the
downside I think still move when you're
eavesdropping so yeah
new to the stream is this fortnight no
thankfully try what give me a like stand
up prom or climb up brother hello my
dude what difficulty is this we're just
playing on the normally like another
prosthetic in this air this in the
States
oh really so like I don't think I ever
got or maybe I did get this I think I
did get that one there's just two
Buddhist guys over there yeah yeah the
monks it's it's a long long way around
there are no difficulty settings we can
talk about cuz we showed it right now I
guess so I mean we think that the Bell
that you guys saw oh you know what would
be nice to have right now the axe which
I do yeah it's gonna say you know you
want my you want my god oh yeah show me
how you did this cuz
like I did I did this kind of just ran
past me get behind them except I can't
show that but basically in like a wider
space I got really frustrated with these
guys cuz I didn't have the ax and the
axe basically like rips their shield ah
yeah which is why the that prosthetic is
so good work anyways yeah I'm not gonna
sit here fighting to shield is news for
now yeah alright yeah he's right there
you guys saw nothing I mean they're kind
of not omnia they're a little on to you
always among Conda me to wear this so
when you find the prosthetics out in the
world you have to take them back to the
sculptor to actually attach them to the
arm so he has to make the actual
mechanism to put it all together so you
don't get it right away
well I can't he target me back hard
again so there isn't a difficulty
setting but we found a bell that you can
ring and get possessed by a demon and it
says it makes things more difficult at
the the possibility of higher rewards so
we assumed that might be like a hard
mode but there is no out right option
for easy normal or hard you think that
I'm gonna run past him and get that
checkpoint oh I can't he's blocking my
way
does this fill the void in my soul for
tenchu it does a pretty good job it's
not right on the money but it's pretty
close you know killing those guys no I
fought this guy I dragged him back I
honestly can't remember what I did I
guess this guy I remember this sucks
that I only have one healing guard
though
it's on is it though
frickin game why are you doing that we
can bring them back over here and then
you won't have to worry about the other
dude no I wanted my back step I wanted
my free back and get that back step go
follow you over here you can probably
jump off this tower together
is there day one patch not that I've
heard of I should kill those guys first
thing is right below you
[Music]
well those guys don't know you're there
anymore that's good I could've sworn
there was another checkpoint that was
closer though I think there's one right
after that fight
how's the game so far very challenging
Jeffrey it's a heck of a time that's
what I did okay he's here he's right
grab hook looks like a game changer I
like I like the what the grappling hook
brings like for just opening up
possibilities and traversal it's a
really cool tool you can know he knows
you're there still but the music's still
going he's just messing with you I don't
know how we're gonna do this man but
without resting and getting my Till's
back be sure that that doesn't go anyway
I haven't gone down there good there is
a branch
[Music]
if I think blood-borne is too heavy for
me can i buy this I think you might be a
better person to answer that but you are
in the middle of tried the McKee recount
er and I failed it's all good
oh yeah if someone thinks that
blood-borne
it might have been too much for them do
you think this is a good option for them
Oh blood-borne was too much cuz I'm
gonna say maybe not no I'm gonna go with
probably not unless you're patient and
want to learn the game cuz I definitely
got frustrated in the beginning of this
game alright I have to just go back and
get the get those prosthetics excuse me
I think I just had to go to sleep you
know okay it's that time all right
you think I need the prosthetics though
I mean you're you're right here you
might as well just double rests a little
rest
more rest much better so we've got it's
1250 now okay okay I got a hurry oh yeah
I'm trying to I'm gonna try to beat that
guy hopefully Oh gaming until death
asked why don't you try to kill him
normally it would be longer more drawn
out and this game is very difficult I
would say it's just it's just like if
you have the opportunity one to knock
off half of a boss's health you take it
why wouldn't you do it I guess it's the
only thing I can think to kind of argue
that like you could do it but
all right let's go try chat I like the
movement run mechanics yeah the
animations are really nice I feel like
there's a way around there and I just
screwed that up somehow like in terms of
like all that stuff that we just had to
deal with
I remember being able to kind of like
bypass some of it I feel like in crime
you just talked me into getting this
game yes I'm not ringing that Bell have
a great day hey you too Red Hulk I'm
glad you were able to come by and hang
out hope you had a good time I hope
everyone else had a good time too if you
did you should definitely subscribe to
the channel so you don't miss a single
stream we do we stream every single
weekday at 11 a.m. Pacific early
gameplay of games like Sakura just cool
dumb things that we like just all sorts
of stuff you can catch it all right here
and I don't want you to miss a thing
just please come back that sound like a
lyric so an Aerosmith song because death
definitely was accident it just makes
the whole fight against them not a thing
I love it both for those of you we're
still hanging out we're here for another
eight minutes do you think you can see
me wrap it up for this I think you can
get him he's a free free kill that guy
that that guy sorry got his bow drawn up
he knows you're there
there you go I never found a way to use
the shirtkin like effectively it's good
against a better player yeah it's good
against the light armored people and
stuff like that so like I like using it
on butterfly in when she jumps and also
in the second phase yeah where'd you
find the ax if you scroll back a little
bit earlier we showed where we we picked
it up it's it's not too far away from
here actually
all right here we go the real fight
I can't believe I just actually gasped
because something like showed up and
scared me
it's amazing I've been excited for it
for months I'm excited for everyone to
get their hands on this because I want
to see I want to see what stuff that
other people find because right now it's
just been a couple of people in the
office and like even even now Taylor and
that you could stab the snake in the eye
like just find out all sorts of cool
something you can do and that's what I'm
excited for
oh my god you're actually not dead okay
[Laughter]
look okay I didn't expect that was good
a lot of people are calling this is this
is gonna be like their the early like
top contender for game of the year it's
got that that big name behind it who's
right there it was it was very very
close that's that's how this game goes
though oh this is what happens when you
start reviving dragon rod spreads it's
sick you gotta get good all right I got
to hurry up I gotta get back there
dang it he was so close I didn't know
that he could stab in the back like
after I had his back open to me yeah
yeah which is my fault I shouldn't have
spammed it I should have just tried to
like jump away my sucks don't think I'll
take the blame on that one repo cue on
the ground though that was a hundred
percent what I put out into the universe
and it definitely came back or just can
do the sprint sprint techniques five
times serpentine zigzag oh yeah you
still got you still got four minutes
you're fine
there's tons of time yaaayyy jeez
that's fine
I had to go to tree
the DMC is a pretty big frontrunner for
me personally for game of the air like
that game a lot
what excuse me
Archer no all right this is very bad
this is the run this is it this
happiness is very bad on multiple fronts
[Music]
I appreciate that you didn't just give
him the assassination you made sure that
it was locked in is easy to get into
this if you haven't played Dark Souls it
might actually be easier for you to get
into if you haven't played Dark Souls
which is a weird thing to say
so we're mentioning earlier there are a
lot of weird things that you kind of
have to unlearn from what you might know
from playing Souls
there it is this guy seems upset I'm
upset
I have to deal with those two jokers - I
think you'll because you didn't get them
- oh no they did come after you want me
or hate them right yeah like just get
the get the stab and then pull back out
but if they're so close
get some distance and single them out
how limited our the healing gourds it
takes a while to get more but you can
also upgrade the effect of the feeling
from them which is a big suggestion
definitely I feel like I don't actually
have the counter it's not something you
have to equip or I'm like oh I did not
mean to just say I don't I don't think
we stack all right here you guys wanted
to see pause so you can pause in the
middle of combat it's wild it's crazy I
totally have it okay yeah be the moment
the enemy thrusts okay I think I think
their weapon actually glows is how I do
it or not
that's good that's good see you one shot
oh yes
me and you both very close to one shot I
win these guys over here gave up they
don't know what the heck's going on you
know what you know what just take the
win
just take the win yeah pick this item up
maybe we're good what we've done it it's
one o'clock on the nose it's perfect
timing just like that
don't you have sword combos not really
not it's more like you just have a
couple of swimming attacks and then you
can mix in like that that's [ __ ] the
spins not not the combat art but the one
where I spun and and slash it's like off
of the dodge yeah so yes pairing is a
thing it doesn't leave them media
vulnerable like Dark Souls yeah it's a
difference at the posture for sure uh
yeah so I guess I was it was good
examples of a lot of things yeah you
know it's obviously not super easy it
started off really easy for me then it
kind of got a little touch-and-go there
John off the snake was cool sure not the
headless dude ripping me a new one was
cool really glad that we got that and
you knew gonna make it work I I know
you're just like him make me feel sad
anyways the review probably sometime end
of this week I think technically the
embargo is tomorrow but I don't want to
tie you know Tomoya onto like a certain
date so it's on the way
we're working that's on the way it's in
the works you know we're gonna do some
guide stuff obviously it's you know I'm
not I won't share too much about my
opinions other than like I think try it
out I think that it's interesting again
though it's definitely for a type of
player I
you know like you you have to know what
you're getting yourself into there's a
lot of stealth that's you it's a big a
big part of it is stealth and I don't
think that's a thing that's happened
really a lot in traditional yeah and I
mean as as you saw you just have to take
advantage of it you know you can still
play it you know in maybe your way or
like how you want to but definitely
you'll gain more benefit out of stealth
thing
there's even cooler stuff down the road
that I can't talk about that kind of
help with some of those things which is
pretty cool so we can't give you guys
any scores or anything other than just
what we played there enjoyed it
there's exploration really cool combat
mechanics are pretty tight like they're
rewarding when you kind of figure it out
it can be punishing though if you don't
really get what you're doing I guess or
at it's something the souls games do you
just learn as you but you got good you
have to get good by playing you got a
runner run against those walls and learn
learn until it works don't be a fool
stay in school at the game well you're
gonna go play dong and Ruffalo yok is a
that's pretty much it
well we appreciate everyone tuning in
thank you so much thank you Ben for
being my partner crime here and helping
me anytime except for that one time he
laughed that was good though
wasn't doing it Ben has never done that
to me before not once
first time not a super sign for
everything though right I guess alright
send us out of here Ben alright
everybody goodbye see you later have a
good day I'm finding the buttons it's
happening you've go we got the mask on
again nope let me get out of here